as some of you may know I explored the
world of tinder a little while ago
Gloria is 74 so since I did people have
been telling me I should try this thing
called Grindr anything about Grindr I
asked a friend to help me out who was
good enough to say yes Billy Eichner
Billy hey thank you so much thanks for
having me I don't want to assume
anything do you know anything about
Grindr if you had experience with Grindr
uh yeah there's a lot of straight people
pretending it's for dating but really
using it for sex a lot okay
Grindr is for basically gay guys not
pretending it's for anything other than
meeting up to have sex so I think you're
gonna have a good time is there any
chance that they'll just be my friend no
I don't even think they're gonna know
who you are you're seeing gay people
don't know who Conan O'Brien is gay man
I do you and I have known each other a
lot a few years yeah but before you met
me you didn't even know who I was is
what you're saying not a clue I think
I'm straight I've been married yeah
happily for a long time very straight
yeah but then there were times there
were times where I'm like you know when
like Ryan Gosling's on the show oh my
god
okay I've opened the Grindr app and it
says build your profile headline try to
sell yourself rich ginger sugar
basically okay I'm just gonna say ginger
sugar dad what about six four very
successful ginger ginger today I mean
this is something I don't talk about a
lot on the air but I am very ginger and
when I'm naked it looks like the base of
a baby birch tree is on fire
this is the most important part need a
photo should I show something that's not
the pose most men you so you're really
gonna differentiate yourself me see I
think that's good oh my god I think
that's horrifying
that's good cheating okay I got this at
a costume shop hey is this look used to
one face I'm a optimistic gay man look
like Dennis the Menace finally came out
here okay oh my god okay look at this
guy
why now realizing why you thought my
torso look bad yeah that's what you're
up against
muscular muscular know what you know but
you know who musky low isn't freckle
that's what you've got on your side
this guy's winter pelt look at our whoa
look at the rug that this guy he's got a
sweater on his shoulder and he's
standing in front of a World War 2
airplane what a casual look right what
do I say you take your airplane
I like your airplane I bet it rises
quickly what about I like it are you
circumcised that's gonna come up by the
way unbelievable okay I just sent it off
I like your airplane you circumcised
what about this guy uh hey hey what's up
you want to get plowed by a rich ginger
oh I think that's Sanjaya
from from American American Idol I did
say you look like Sanjaya you look like
Sanjaya am i you're Melinda Doolittle
we lost like no I don't know in the
Doolittle was like she came in like
forth like season five American Idol
okay it's unbelievable can I would he
know whom we went to do a little yes of
course he will
don't work to you what do they say what
do they say nice profile profile Joey
[Applause]
what
Joey's a nice-looking man in a suit I
like Joey yeah hold on there's another
guy that messaged you okay I gotta play
the field gonna play one guy said hey
another guy said what's up and enery and
he wrote hi Conan I think it's Lee
Harvey Oswald are you LOL says looking
to suck okay look at you suck wants to
know how you are and then isn't it cute
looking to suck added a fun little lol
we're gonna stop and we're gonna I have
a really good feeling about looking too
son
Oh someone's really looking to suck rose
back again just chilling a little bored
so you're a fan of Conan pop I am
[Applause]
oh you've got a lot of messages hey what
are we looking at [ __ ] someone sent two
photos then if you are who I think you
are I'm in love I like that guy he looks
like the brother from Fresh Prince okay
we get back you bet it's who you think
it is okay here we go you know I hate
this I'm already planning my life with
him oh we have a response oh it's from
the Sanjaya guys so Chaya what'd he say
what'd he say we said you wrote
you look like Sanjaya and then he wrote
Sanjaya I told you not everybody knows
who sent giant everybody sure yes oh my
god it's our friend the one I like one
who likes you what does he say you wrote
hey yes it's me how are you want to meet
and he wrote I'd love to
[Applause]
yeah okay
things are happening really fast now he
wants to meet me yeah we have to get in
our special customized Grindr van check
it out there it is
gotcha this is my car where's the
grinder then check this oh my god out
this is incredible yeah oh oh look a
bowl of condoms
yeah we're not using these well no we
should be definitely
I don't know what this is this is me
yeah this is Lu you put it on your house
it determined who's what we're about to
find out its coding a bottom hello hello
hey how are you Colonel Brian hey meet
you I'm Anthony Anthony Anthony let me
ask you do you like what you see I'm
beyond it oh it's okay I was like look
nothing has to happen right away but we
could go you know and go to an
Applebee's or something
is it Applebee's no don't you want to
he's got a cut he's got to calm down
he's got a calm you know I know what you
were trying to do but no one's ever said
do you wanna you know they are I do
they're still it's just share it just
[ __ ] and I'm not that guy hold on commas
this is like a his version of
trick-or-treat yeah okay let's be honest
it wasn't a love connection or a hookup
but I did make a new friend in a
supermarket parking lot so thanks a lot
Grindr
thanks Grindr
[Applause]
you
you